DON'T FORGET TO DOWNLOAD THE 5
THINGS PODCAST.
GO TO CNN COME/5THINGS.
>>> AS VLADIMIR PUTIN CONTINUES
THIS INVASION AND THE HARSH
CRACKDOWN INSIDE RUSSIA REALLY,
SLAMMING ALL SIGNS OF DEFENSE,
SOME WORDS FROM HIS PAST ARE
TAKING ON NEW MEANING.
>> JOHN AVLON SENIOR CNN
POLITICAL AFFAIRS CORRESPONDENT
AND BIANNA GOLODRYGA.
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THAT
CLIP, HE'S SERVING IN THE
YELTSIN GOVERNMENT.
HE'S RECENTLY BEEN IN ST.
PETERSBURG AT A MUNICIPAL LEVEL.
HIM TALKING ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF DEMOCRACY, THE RUSSIAN
TENDENCY TO SEEK COMFORT IN A
STRONG HAND, A TOTALITARIAN
FIGURE.
WHETHER HE HAD ANY INKLING IT
MIGHT BE HIM, YOU'D HAVE TO BE
IN HIS HEAD.
WHAT'S DOUBLING IS SOMETIMES
THAT STRONG HAND CAN STRANGLE
US.
PUTIN IS ALMOST LOOKING INTO THE
FUTURE IN THAT IMAGINING WHAT
MIGHT HAPPEN TO HIS COUNTRY,
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO HIS
COUNTRY, THAT BRIEF MOMENT OF
DEM ACCURACY WHICH IS SQUANDERED
BY HIM, 20 YEARS OF HIM BEING IN
POWER.
>> I THINK OF THE RUSSIAN
ANALYST, NINA PORSHOVA.
SHE WAS ASKED RECENTLY IN AN
INTERVIEW IF SHE COULD DESCRIBE
PUTIN IN ONE WORD.
SHE SAID KGB.
THAT'S WHERE THIS TAKES YOU.
GOING BACK TO HIS MENTALITY, HIS
TRAINING, HIS FRAME OF MIND.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHEN THAT INTERVIEW OR WHEN
THOSE WORDS WERE SPOKEN.
THAT WAS IN 1996, WHEN THE
COUNTRY WAS IN THE MIDST OF AN
ECONOMIC FREE FALL AND COLLAPSE,
FOLLOWING THE DISSOLUTION.
YOU HAVE A SOVIET UNION
COMPLETELY SHATTERED, MULTIPLE
STATES IN ECONOMIC COLLAPSE,
NONE RELYING ON STATES
THEMSELVES, IN TERMS OF
ENTERPRISE, PRIVATE SECTORS AND
BUSINESS.
THE SHOT FROM THE WEST HAD
FAILED.
THERE HAD BEEN A MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF POVERTY AND HUNGER THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY, DISARRAY, AND CRIME
WAS UP AS WELL.
THIS WAS ONE OF THE WEAKEST
MOMENTS IN RUSSIA'S HISTORY.
THE CURRENCY DEVALUED, DEFAULTED
IN THE 1998 FINANCIAL CRISIS IN
RUSSIA.
THIS WAS ALL LEADING UP TO WHERE
HE WAS TAKING THIS CONVERSATION
AND THAT TRAIN OF THOUGHT.
THAT IS THIS COUNTRY IS IN
DISARRAY AND NEEDS ORDER, AND
ORDER IS WHERE HE TOOK THAT
COUNTRY QUITE LITERALLY.
>> JAKE DID A NICE JOB
YESTERDAY, GIVEN A GUY WHO LOVED
TOTALITARIANISM FROM THE
BEGINNING, HOW MUCH THE UNITED
STATES HAS ACCOMMODATED HIM OVER
THE YEARS.
NOW IT'S COMING HOME TO ROOST.
>> I WANT TO SHIFT GEARS AND
LOOK AT U.S. POLICY.
JIM SCIUTTO NOTED THIS ON AIR, A
LOT OF THINGS IN MEASURE THAT
TWO, THREE WEEKS AGO THE U.S.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION BASICALLY
SAID THEY WOULDN'T DO NOW SEEMS
LIKE THEY'RE ON THE VERGE OF
HAPPENING.
THERE DOES APPEAR TO BE AN URGE
TO STOP THE IMPORT OF RUSSIAN
OIL TORQUES BAN PURCHASING OF
RUSSIAN OIL, MAYBE SOON, COULD
BE TODAY, COULD BE TOMORROW.
THE IDEA OF TRANSFERRING THESE
MIGS FROM POLAND TO I-95, THAT
COULD HAPPEN TODAY, TOMORROW.
A LOT OF THE STUFF THAT WAS
UNIMAGINABLE, VERY IMAGINABLE
NOW.
>> THAT'S HOW FAST THINGS ARE
MOVING ON THE GROUND AND THE
CONSTANT RATCHETING UP OF
PRESSURE.
WHAT BIDEN ANNOUNCED IN THE
STATE OF THE UNION IS HIS
OPENING BID.
HE SAID HE WOULD PUT A CRACKDOWN
ON RUSSIAN OIL, PARTLY BECAUSE
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT RISING
GAS PRICES.
GOLDMAN SACKS PUT OUT A REPORT
SAYING IT MIGHT NOT HAVE THAT
MUCH EFFECT.
AS LONG AS OTHER COUNTRIES IN
THE U.S. RATCHETS UP PRODUCTION,
MAYBE A NO GAS TAX --
>> IKS MAKES YOU THINK LEADING
UP TO THE WAR HOW THE U.S.
SIGNALED THERE WERE TABLETOP
ISSUES, LAYING OUT ANY SCENARIO
OF WHAT THEY MIGHT BE PREPARED
FOR.
I WONDER IF THEY WERE READY FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN CROSSING A
RUBICON.
WE HAVE A SCENARIO WITH U.S.
OFFICIALS PERHAPS RETURNING TO
VENEZUELA TO RELEASE SANCTIONS
AGAINST VENEZUELA AND THE MADURO
REGIME TO HELP EASE GLOBAL OIL
CONCERNS.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE THEY DIDN'T
PROJECT THE BRUTALITY OF PUTIN.
BUT IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE THAT NO
ONE IMAGINED THE WORLD WOULD
JOIN TOGETHER IN RESPO